eu vim falar pra vocês hoje a
importância da educação uma educação
diferenciada uma educação de amor pela
vida
nós perdemos o contato nosso contato com
a natureza
isso é lastimável muitos muito da
situação que o mundo se encontra hoje é
em decorrência desse afastamento nosso
com a natureza e isso é fácil de ser
explicado porque a maior parte da nossa
população vive nos meios urbanos ea
natureza está cada vez mais escassa a
educação hoje ela precisa é despertar na
gente
uau o maravilhamento como é que eu me
reconectar com tudo o que está à nossa
volta e o brasil tem uma
responsabilidade muito grande
nós vivemos num país que chama de mega
diversidade em tudo nós somos pioneiros
temos mais a água que tem mais a árvore
tem mais aves é um país que está sempre
entre os cinco países que mais têm e
mais a gente se distanciou essa
reeducação ela é possível há 30 anos
atrás
minha família e eu nós fomos morar em
teodoro sampaio e no interior do estado
de são paulo extremo oeste e lá a
floresta é floresta atlântica é de
interior onde menos de 2% resto e mesmo
assim a população achava que porque não
derrubar tudo pra ter uma fazenda de
gado porque pelo menos eo tio e me dá
leite porque do jeito que está não serve
pra nada
mas durante esses 30 anos nós
desenvolvemos um programa continuado que
valorizasse as espécies ea própria mata
e dentro desse banco genético esse é o
modo diabo e as matas que circundam o
morro do diabo é é um banco genético
porque hoje é resto
poucas manchas de mata como essas no
interior de são paulo onde vive várias
espécies muitas ameaçadas como onça é
uma borboleta que só existe lá eo mico
leão preto
o mico leão preto foi a razão pela qual
a minha vida mudou
o cláudio foi estudar como é o trabalho
de doutorado dele e nós mudamos falar e
agente atraiu um grupo de estudantes
ainda jovens que ficaram próximos de nós
nesse estudo então toda a nossa
experiência serviu como uma grande
escola
o mico leão preto e assim como todos os
elementos da natureza seres livres da
natureza têm muito a nos ensinar muito
pouco deles são estudados mas por
exemplo domingo tem algumas lições que
nós temos bastante a aprender
primeiro eles vivem uma família ea
família um cuida do outro as mães essa
parte eu adoro por ser tão feminina é
são protegidas quando elas têm os bebês
ea família inteira cuida dos filhos pra
que ela quando ela vá aumentar ela
esteja descansada e feliz e honra
depois eles são os filhos mais velhos
ajudam a criar os filhos menores porque
eles aprendem a a formar uma família
só depois disso é que eles saem para
formar sua própria achar seu par ou sua
parte ea e formar uma nova família eles
já vão estar sabendo como fazer e eles
são de fato monógamos o casal alfa que o
casal que procria ele fica junto para o
resto da vida
você vê que a gente tem bastante a
aprender com eles
nem todos naturalmente espero q enfim
deixa pra lá e um mico o que foi
interessante é que o cláudio achava que
só estudará um mico e as suficientes e
então ele passava o dia inteiro na mata
e eu comecei a trabalhar com parte de
educação ambiental para sensibilizar as
pessoas
mas depois a gente começou a ver que não
era suficiente uma coisa que é
importante de se fazer era linkar juntar
um fragmento de mata com o outro pra
poder o mico sair de uma área com mata
encontrar seu par em outro para não ter
problemas de consanguinidade
principalmente os pequenos fragmentos
então esse corredor de mata eu tenho
orgulho de dizer que o maior corredor de
mata atlântica já plantada e foi por um
dos nossos pesquisadores a equipe dele e
toda a equipe nossa do pontal
isso é concreto está acontecendo e está
sendo ampliado
a nossa idéia é de que todos os
pedacinhos de mata do pontal eles possam
ser conectados pra que as espécies
circulem não só um mico a gente usa o
mico como um símbolo mas é muito além do
que a gente viu é que também não podia
só cuidar da espécie
a gente tinha que cuidar também das
pessoas o pontal do paranapanema extremo
oeste de são paulo é uma região que tem
muito conflito onde houve muitas
famílias de assentados se mudando para
lá
nós começamos a pensar de que maneira
que a gente consegue integrar o social
ambiental e econômico então promovemos
diversas ações para que as pessoas
também melhorarem de vida bonito de se
descolar e dor tem um lado social porque
muitas das espécies que são plantadas
nos viveiros de árvores nativas são
pelos assentados do movimento enquanto
cláudia e eu chegamos lá ainda bem
jovens e com os fios bem pequenos
a gente não imaginava que ia ser tão
complexo mas sinceramente tão
gratificante eu acho que a paixão que
comentou na gente foi contagiante
porque hoje a gente tem uma instituição
que chama ip que é também a árvore
símbolo de são paulo que atrai os jovens
que também querem mudar o mundo
é essa equipe do ip da copa tem muito
orgulho e adam pessoa dessas foi
empoderada pra fazer aquilo que
realmente ama aquilo que realmente acha
que vale a pena e o que é muito
interessante de ver é que ai de quem
hoje em teodoro sampaio depois de um
processo de educação continuada que era
desmatar ou fazer mal à natureza o
parque estadual do morro do diabo e o
mico-leão-preto se tornar um símbolo da
região com muito orgulho da população
local eo mico leão preto é hoje também a
espécie símbolo do estado de são paulo e
isso foi bem recente
agora educar para a vida é uma na
verdade é o amor pela vida é não é tão
simples porque as pessoas se sentem
mesmo mais afastadas elas não estão mais
acostumados mas a gente tem que criar
meios mecanismos de fazer com que essa
conexão ela aconteça
mas será que a gente é capaz de amar de
verdade
será que a gente é capaz de respeitar é
porque a gente está vendo cada vez mais
há a predominância ainda do nosso gem
egoísta porque a gente não evolui porque
a gente não consegue um patamar é de
celebração da vida e de realmente a
olhar à nossa volta e ver tanta
diversidade o mundo levou bilhões de
anos para cada espécie dessas existir
como é que nós uma espécie que se diz a
mais inteligente de todas se dá o
direito de usurpar tanto da natureza e
do ser humano
se a gente fosse ético de verdade
será que a gente precisaria de leis lei
para proteger áreas da nossa própria
ganância
quando a gente forma partes ou unidades
de conservação
a nancy insustentável nunca limite leis
para proteger e índios
hoje a situação indígena do brasil está
calamitosa
é vergonhosa é triste leis para proteger
crianças e adolescentes porque a gente
precisa dessas leis e hoje os imigrantes
que são jogados de um lado para o outro
como que a gente pode ser proativos em
situações em que na vez de ter a
exclusão a gente tenha a inclusão
então o amor pela vida é algo que é um
desafio não é tão simples da gente é
despertar nas pessoas mas ele é
fundamental pra mim é o único jeito
dentro do ipi a gente tem uma escola a
idéia é de semear é essas pequenas
sementes as pessoas saírem com é uma
capacitação porque não adianta a gente
só tocar a mente aumentar o conhecimento
a gente tem que tocar o coração também é
uma combinação e essa combinação nem
sempre é simples a gente tem a
predominância durante todos esses anos
de ser racional de valorizar aquilo que
é concreto mas os valores da gente
precisa mudar não o planeta não aguenta
mais tanta exploração nem dos recursos e
nem do ser humano que habita a terra é
esse contágio é que eu acho interessante
porque quando você começa a trabalhar
esse amor pela vida as pessoas querem se
chegar e a negatividade de todo esse
processo ela precisa de algum jeito é
ficar um pouco de lado
a gente tem sempre que mostrar que é se
é possível a gente a gente chegar a
soluções a nossa mente devia tá
preocupado o tempo todo com soluções e
não com problemas
a gente tem que chegar a um patamar de
evolução onde a gente se celebre a vida
ea teia dessa vida
a gente faz parte dela
então a educação ela não devia ser com
adjetivos
eu trabalho com educação ambiental e mas
a educação não devia ter o adjetivo
ambiental ou educação para
sustentabilidade ou educação é sexual ou
qualquer outro tipo de adjetivo a
educação é de fato com letra maiúscula
ela devia contemplar tudo o que é
necessário para formar um ser humano
íntegro e ético correto que curta o belo
a estética ea ética para mim elas estão
muito juntas porque quando você descobre
algo que é belo
você quer cuidar e quando você quer
cuidar
você tem um trio ligações de fio de
ligação e é isso que eu acho que é
importante a outra coisa é que tem que
ser divertido
não adianta a gente só falar de problema
a gente o problema ele cria barreiras no
nosso pensamento
nós temos que o tempo todo pensar que é
possível e trazer sempre alegria para o
nosso trabalho
eu acredito que a gente é capaz
a gente foi criado ao tempo todo pra
pensar que nós não somos capazes
a gente aceita que tem pronto ea gente
hoje está precisando de empreendedores
que mudem o mundo e eu acho que é por
isso que quando me chamam de utópico eu
digo olha isso é um elogio e isso não é
uma crítica porque eu tenho sonhos e o
meu sonho é de contaminar as pessoas
para que elas exame
o meu sonho é para contaminar as pessoas
para que elas a minha vida tudo que está
à nossa volta
tudo que nós enfrentamos disse planeta
tudo que está em nós
nós somos maravilha muito obrigado